Tenemos otra vez nuestra balanza, hay una cierta cantidad de masa del lado izquierdo, así como del
lado derecho, podemos observar que nuestra
balanza está en equilibrio.
Esta vez utilicé la letra "x" para denotar
a cada una de nuestras masas misteriosas
y lo que queremos saber es,
¿cuál es la masa de cada una de ellas?
de las masas misteriosas.
Y me gustaría invitarte a pensar,
que es lo que podríamos hacer para saber
¿cuánta masa en kilogramos tiene cada una de estas masas misteriosas?
Por ejemplo, si pudiéramos hacer algo a ambos
lados de la balanza o nada más a alguno de los lados...
te voy a dar algunos segundos para que lo pienses.
Tal vez se te ocurra pensar si yo pudiera
terminar con una sola de las masas misteriosas
del lado izquierdo y conservar el equilibrio
en la balanza, entonces ese sería el valor
de la masa misteriosa y en principio la idea
es válida, entonces tal vez pensaríamos,
si quito dos de las masas misteriosas...
a ver, vamos a buscar un color apropiado
y las elimino... pero si elimino estas dos
masas y nada más dejo una sola,
entonces el lado izquierdo de la balanza tendrá menos masa, será más
ligero y entonces el plato del lado izquierdo
subirá y el derecho bajará.
Y entonces pensarás...
¡Ah! ya entendí lo que está pasando, si yo quito
algo del lado izquierdo, tendré que quitar
exactamente lo mismo del lado derecho para
mantener el equilibrio, pero si quito dos
masas del lado derecho, pues no es una solución,
porque no sabemos el valor de las masas misteriosas.
Otra idea puede ser, si yo dejara 1/3 de lo
que hay en cada uno de los lados, mantendría
el equilibrio o lo que es lo mismo multiplicar
por 1/3 cada uno de los lados.
La masa total de este lado, es exactamente
igual a la masa total del otro lado,
si yo tomo 1/3 de la masa total de este lado y 1/3 de la masa total del otro lado, serían lo mismo.
Así que dejemos 1/3 del total de lo que hay
de este lado, que es equivalente a multiplicarlo
por 1/3, si quito dos masas de este lado,
solo me quedaré con 1/3 de lo que hay.
Y de este lado veamos cuanto tenemos, tenemos,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 masas,
si multiplico 1/3 por 9 obtengo 3, entonces tendré que
quitar éstas que están de este lado
y me va a quedar simplemente 3.
Y con esto tengo una tercera parte de lo que
había del lado derecho y una tercera parte
de lo que había del lado izquierdo y la balanza
continua en equilibrio,
porque tenemos una tercera parte de lo
que había de cada lado.
Y podemos concluir que "x" es igual a 3.